حينما يتحدث وزير الدفاع جالنت عن ما يقول
انها اخطاء صعبه وقعت اثناء العمليه التي
قتل فيها ثلاثه من الاسرى الاسرائيليين
على يد قوات الاحتلال نفسها ويقول اننا
نمر باوقات ضاغطه وكذلك يقول المتحدث هجار
نفس هذا الكلام ويقول اننا نواجه امورا لم
نواجهها من قبل ماذا يعني بالامور او يعني
ما الذي يمكن ان يدفع جنديا الى ان يقتل
دون تمييز من يرفع له الرايه البيضاء سوى
انه في حاله شديده جدا من الهلع او في
حاله انه يقتل دون تمييز من يستسلم او من
لا
يستسلم يعني بالتاكيد هذه الحاله تعكس ما
تفضلت به من حاله اولا تدني الروح
المعنويه والروح القتاليه عند الجنود
الاسرائيليين نحن نعلم ان الجنود
الاسرائيليين منذ يوم 17 يوم تنفيذ عمليه
طوفان الاقصى كان هناك هزيمه نفسيه
ومعنويه وعسكريه ل نخبه النخبه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي اللي هي فرقه غزه يعني حينما
استطاع 1200 مقاوم فلسطيني ان يهزموا 20
ال من جيش النخبه ويسيطروا على الثكنات
العسكريه وهذه المعلومات وصلت الى كل جندي
اسرائيلي بتفاصيلها فلذلك حينما توجه
الجندي الاسرائيلي الى داخل قطاع غزه توجه
بمعنويات وروح قتاليه متدنيه وهو مسكون
بالصدمه والرعب من يوم س7 عش اضاف اضافه
الى انه يحمل عقيده هني بعل انه ذاهب الى
القتل والاسر لذلك هو يقتل بدون تمييز هو
لا لا يملك يعني هو فاقد للاعصاب لديه هوس
الحياه والموت بما بما معناه ان اي شيء
متحرك في غطاء غزه يعتبر عدوا له فبالتالي
انا بتقديري حتى حتى الانضباط حتى
القوانين التي يتحدث عنها الجيش
الاسرائيلي بان ان بانه منضبط وانه يراعي
القوانين الدوليه والقوانين الانسانيه ثبت
بالدليل القاطع انه لا لا علاقه له به من
الناحيه
الانضباطيه
حينما ومعروف عند الجيش وعند اي عسكري في
العالم حينما يكون هناك مدني اعزل لا يجوز
اطلاق النار عليه باي شكل من الاشكال فكيف
حينما يكون هناك جنود ويتحدثون باللغه
العبريه ويحملون الرايات البيضاء وحاولوا
اكثر من مره ان يؤكدوا لزملائهم انهم جنود
اسرائيليين هذا يدل على مدى الضعف ومدى
التفكك الموجود في
الاخلاق عند الجنود الاسرائيليين حتى لو
ادعوا بانهم ربما يكونوا فلسطينيين وهذه
بتقديري ايضا جريمه اكبر بمعنى ان الجندي
الاسرائيلي يريد قتل الفلسطيني تحت اي شكل
من الاشكال حتى لو كان مستسلما و رافع عن
الرايه البيضاء وهذا هذا يدل على ما ما
تقوله القيادات الاسرائيليه اننا نواجه
ظروف صعبه نواجه ظروف معقده الكل وهذه من
المرات القليله نسمع القيادات الاسرائيليه
وخاصه الرتب العاليه من الجيش الاسرائيلي
يتحدثون عن ضعف في الاداء في اداء الجيش
الاسرائيلي ويتحدثون عن سلبيات دائما
وابدا كانوا يتشدقون ويرفعون السقف عالي
في في في تسليط الضوء على الانجازات الان
كل الضوء مسلط من رئيس الوزراء ووزير
الحرب ورئيس هييه الاركان كل الضوء مسلط
على اخفاقات وعلى ضعف وعلى ظروف معقده
وعلى ان ما زالت هناك جيوب للمقاومه وان
المقاومه تقاتل بمعنى هذا اعتراف ان
المقاوم قويه صلح ه هذا لا يصلح المشكله
التي تحدثت عنها في البدايه وي تدني الروح
المعنويه
للجنود الاسرائيليين يعني حينما يقول هجار
انهم ان الجنود يمرون باوقات صعبه
ويتعرضون لمواقف غير مسبوقه هذا يفت في
عضد المقاتلين اصلا في الارض كيف يمكن ان
يصدر هذا
التصريح لا بالتاكيد بالتاكيد يعني هم لا
يستطيعون اخفاء هذه الحقائق على الارض
يعني الجنود
الاسرائيليين يتابعون ويعرفون ويسمعون
ويشاهدون
يعني اليوم وبالامس وقبل امس بلث المقاومه
الفلسطينيه مقاطع فيديو لعمليات بطوليه
سواء كما عمليه جحر الديك او
عمليه او عمليات قنص الدبابات والاشتباك
مع الجنود الاسرائيليين من مسافه صفر هذه
كلها مع الجنود الاسرائيليين والجنود
الاسرائيليين يتناقلون هذه المعلومات عبر
وسائل الاتصال فيما بينهم او عبر التلاقي
احيانا فبالتالي هذه العمليات البطوليه
ومهارات الميدان
المستوى العالي جدا والشجاعه عند
المقاومين الفلسطينيين وزمام المبادره
ونصب الكمائن
والنجا ونجاحهم في قنص الدبابات وقتل
الجنود الاسرائيليين كلها هذه تضعف من
الروح المعنويه والروح القتاليه عند
الجنود
الاسرائيليين شكرا جزيلا لك السيد واصف
عريقات الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه كان
معنا من رام الله شكرا